hallo liebe leute wir fahren heute zug
und deshalb machen wir heute ein video
für euch über das zugfahren in
deutschland
[Musik]
als erstes rede darüber welche züge ist
überhaupt gibt und welche anbieter es
gibt der größte anbieter ist die
deutsche bahn habt ihr bestimmt schon
mal gehört die deutsche bahn gehört dem
deutschen staat und sie bedient fast
alle strecken in deutschland
daneben gibt es ein paar private zug
anbieter die jetzt immer stärker werden
in letzter zeit aber sie fahren im
moment nur auf bestimmten strecken
es gibt verschiedene arten von zügen es
gibt regional züge die fahren in den
kurzen distanzen und in bestimmten
regionen und für die langen distanzen
gibt es zwei züge den intercity und der
intercity express natürlich gibt es da
für englisch nahmen wir sitzen jetzt
gerade in einem ic also einem etwas
älteren zog er ist nicht so modern und
nicht so schnell wie der ece aber
günstiger und jetzt gehen wir mit euch
mal durch den zug und zeigen euch wie es
im zug aussieht
meistens sitzt man in einem zug in so
einem großraumabteil das heißt dass
viele menschen in einem raum sitzen
es gibt jedoch auch kleine geschlossene
abteile heute ist unser zug ziemlich
leer
jan schon ich haben ein ganzes abteil
für uns alleine
genau genommen haben wir sogar zwei
abteile kenianisch hat sich ins
kinderabteil gesetzt um einen eigenen
tisch zu haben jetzt ein wichtiges thema
für euch wie kaufe ich ein ticket und
was muss ich dabei beachten ein ticket
kaufen kann nämlich kompliziert sein
also der vorgang selber ist gar nicht so
kompliziert aber man muss wissen dass
man ein ticket vorher online kaufen
sollte und dass man es auch möglichst
früh buchen sollte wenn man einfach
spontan zum bahnhof geht und dort ein
ticket kauft dann zahlt man den normalen
preis an diesem einen tag und diese
preise sind einfach wahnsinnig teuer
also richtig irrsinnig teuer
ein beispiel wir fahren oft von berlin
nach münster diese fahrt dauert ungefähr
vier stunden und ein normales ticket für
diesen für diese strecke sind 98 euro
und 98 euro ist einfach ein preis den
ich niemals zahlen
das heißt wenn ja schon dich von berlin
nach münster fahren und wieder zurück
und wir würden das ticket einfach
spontan am bahnhof kaufen würden wir 400
euro ausgeben
stattdessen fahren wir jetzt gerade für
20 euro pro person das heißt 40 euro hin
40 euro zurück
80 euro im vergleich zum 400 euro das
sind also nur 20 prozent des
originalpreises und so fahren wir immer
das ist ja eigentlich ein bisschen
komisch wenn man sich das so vorstellt
und wenn man das nicht weiß kann es sein
dass man nach deutschland kommt und man
geht einfach zum bahnhof und man sagt
ich will ein ticket für den nächsten zug
nach berlin und plötzlich zahlt man
wahnsinnig viel geld das solltet ihr
nicht machen sondern vorher online
gucken wie die preise sind manchmal gibt
es günstige uhrzeiten manchmal gibt es
günstige tage und dann kann man
eigentlich auch günstig fahren das
einzige was man nicht machen kann bei
der deutschen bahn ist spontan verreisen
abschließend noch einmal 4 tipps für
euch die ihr unbedingt beachten sollte
wenn ihr zum ersten
bahnfahrt in deutschland tipp 1 ist fad
bahn denn bahnfahren ist eigentlich die
schönste art und weise deutschland zu
erkunden und viel netter als mit dem
auto zu fahren oder mit dem bus zu
fahren busse sind zwar billiger aber
viel unbequemer autos sind zwar
unabhängiger aber sie sind eigentlich
der mann entfernt den ganzen tag selber
und kann gar nicht relaxen so wie ich
jetzt gerade jeden der bahn und
flugzeuge gibt es zwar auch zwischen den
großen städten aber das ist meistens
nicht so umweltfreundlich und lohnt sich
auch nicht wirklich zweiter tipp habe
ich schon gesagt fahrt niemals spontan
irgendwo hin sondern plant zumindest ein
paar stunden am besten tage vorher denn
die günstigen tickets bekommt man bis zu
24 stunden vorher landab 24 stunden wird
relativ teuer
tipp 3 das solltet ihr wissen wenn ihr
einen bestimmten sitzplatz haben möchtet
in einem normalen ticket ist keine
reservierung enthalten
in manchen ländern wie zum beispiel in
polen seit ihr das gewöhnt dass sie ein
ticket kauft und dann bekommt ihr euren
sitzt jetzt in deutschland ist das nicht
so und wenn ihr auf einer strecke fahrt
die sehr stark frequentiert ist also
sehr viele leute fahren zum beispiel
nach der arbeit um nach hause zu kommen
dann kann es sein dass ganz viele leute
stehen und ihr keinen sitzplatz hat das
muss man vorher wissen wann man so etwas
braucht und wir selber so wir buchen
nicht so oft reservierung ist weil
meistens findet man sowieso selbst ein
sitzplatz und dass wir mal stehen
mussten in einem zug
das kommt vielleicht bei jeder
dreißigste fahrt vor also das lohnt sich
nicht dafür immer ein ticket zu
reservieren
tipp hier der letzte tipp für euch ist
ganz wichtig dass wir diesen fehler
nicht macht denn den fehler macht man
einmal und dann nicht noch mal ist sich
aus versehen in die erste klasse setzt
jetzt denke ich vielleicht wieso ist das
so schlimm ich setze mich aus versehen
die falsche klasse
das wird der schaffner hole verstehen
wenn ich ein ausländer bin und mich
nicht auskenne
so ist das aber nicht denn die schaffner
nehmen wenig rücksicht dafür dass man
irgendetwas nicht versteht oder nicht
weiß wenn man sich auch so sieht die
erste klasse setzt kann es sehr gut sein
dass der schaffner kommt und sagt moment
du hast gar keine erste klasse ticket
jetzt musst du erst mal 50 euro
nachzahlen oder strafe zahlen und das
ist schon ein paar mal passiert wo ich
auch dabei war und das ist ein bisschen
mehr peinlich von der bahn finde ich
aber das solltet ihr einfach wissen
achtet darauf in welcher klasse ihr
sitzt es gibt nur zwei klassen erste
klasse ist für reiche leute und die
zweite klasse ist für alle normalen
menschen
[Musik]
das war unser video über das bahnfahren
janosch verabschiedet sich jetzt von
euch in dem er euch zu links und wenn
ihr nach fragen habt zum bahnfahren dann
schreibt sie unbedingt hier in die
kommentare und wir versuchen sie
natürlich für euch zu beantworten
jetzt könnt ihr noch ein päckchen werden
als patriot erhaltet ihr jede woche
interaktive übungen zu easy german und
ihr könnt unseren kanal abonnieren
darüber freuen wir uns sehr wir sehen
uns bald wieder nämlich schon am sonntag
bis dann
[Musik]